This video is made possible by Backblaze get a 15 day free
trial@backblaze.com forward slash biographics.
It's a real work of art that comes to represent the entire movement,
the birthdays Monet's waterlilies and impressionism, for example,
or malaise Ophelia, and the Pre-Raphaelites in today's case,
nothing represents surrealism quite like the image of a melting clock.
No artists better encapsulates the field of surrealism more than
Salvador Dali. If you know nothing about art,
if you grow up insides that compounds from the village and have never seen
pencil put to paper, you know,
that melting clocks probably means things are about to get weird.
One of the most referenced images in the modern Canon inspiring jokes and
everything from the Simpsons to Looney tunes,
the persistence of memory is the brain child of none,
other than all-boys Salvador,
the genre defining multimedia artists best known for living a
life. That was almost as weird as the subject he painted,
depending on the source.
The mousing clock represents either the impermanence of time or the melting of
cheese. It's a deeply ironic image,
but the greater irony lies in the fact that during his life,
the man who would come to represent surrealism,
found himself kicked out of the movement by the very friends and colleagues who
Rose to fame with him
Born in 1904 to a middle-class family. Dolly began painting early,
showing a formidable commands of impressionism and had his first public gallery
show. At the age of 14, he was by all accounts,
a shy and introverted child who spent much of his time playing around the Rocky
coast of catechesis and Spain.
It was a favorite vacation spot for his family and as the eventual site of his
first and best loved house, while he and his sister were close,
both of them often felt overshadowed by the ghost of their parents' first child
who died at the age of two shortly before Darlie's birth.
He would later paint a portrait of his brother and often described him as the
first version of myself,
but conceived too much in the absolute it's impossible to overstate.
The impact of casts had on Dolly's development as an artist,
the alien Rocky shores, visible on so many of his canvases,
the washed out beaches populated by lone bathers,
all of these trace back to the days that he spent wandering around the tide
bulls gazing in ore and horror Ash, the full mystery of undersea life,
a morphous jellyfish, and radial [inaudible],
which he and his father loved to eat.
His early work is often painted against barren landscapes marked by odd rock
formations in the distance,
a callback to his much loved coast where the oddly pitted and almost
alien landscape suggests an impossible array of creatures trapped in stone,
waiting to leap upwards and drag you into the council of light nightmare that
they escaped from the figure of the sleeping head referred to as the great
masturbator is rumored to have been inspired by one specific fallen Boulder
arched, like a kidney bean and pitted with a sponge-like array of holes.
One can easily envision a young Dolly staring at this rock, imagining it,
some fantastical monster cowering over in the fetal position.
Maybe he imagined it as himself hiding from his father's wrath.
Even during his youth, that relationship was Rocky.
His father's stringent discipline was softened by his mother's dutiful cuddling.
So she died when he was only 16.
He described it as the greatest blow I had experienced in my life.
His father married his mother, sister Patty a year later,
but this relationship did not seem to troubled Ali as disagreeable as they
might've been. Dolly's.
Father was an ardent supporter of his son's autistic developments paying for
books of impressionist paintings and personal tutors.
He even went so far as to arrange a gallery showing for his 17 year old son.
The location was the municipal fitter Infor Guerrez,
which would later become the Darley theater museum.
The very building he would eventually die in if Dolly ever remarked upon the
irony of dying in the place, which birthed him as an artist,
it was never recorded as it would eventually be. Donnie's controversial art,
which drove them apart.
One must wonder if his father ever regretted supporting his creative endeavors
in the first place.
So much drama and strife was birthed from a single act of support.
Let this be a lesson to fathers listening today,
never support your children unless they become the next Salvador
College Salvador. Dani studied at the San Fernando Royal Academy of fine arts.
He made friends with artists like Lewis, Brunel, and Frederico Garcia, Lorca.
The latter of whom held a deepen unrequited passion for Dolly.
Now it's easy to start from the popular image of adult Dolly as an exuberance
anteater earning weirdo,
and simply make it smaller to represent his youth.
But he was actually quite shy in school among his friends.
He was considered to be bad with girls, that traits,
which would very much resolve itself with sufficient time.
He and his friends studied the art movements emerging in Barcelona and Paris,
as well as the new and controversial theories of academics like Freud.
Dolly would go on to paint some of the first Cubist wax ever produced in Madrid,
starting with the geometric cabaret scene though,
it often takes over a thousand words to describe a picture up.
It's easy to say this one is like if Keith Herring did the cover art for a
smooth jazz album that was sold exclusively at Starbucks after accusing his
professors of being unqualified to judge.
And he dropped out shortly before his final exams in 1926,
normally that kind of stunt lands you in a factory sewing belts and buckles onto
hat spot. When you're already friends with Pablo Picasso,
all that was left for Dolly to do was growing a mustache and start blowing
people's minds.
By the time he to graduate, Dolly.
Had already cultivated an image of an eccentric dandy dressing in stockings and
knee breeches.
Like he was a lesson aristocrat waiting in line at the guillotine.
It's somewhat refreshing to know that at school kids remain unchanged across
history and geography with the notable exception.
That's the weirdly dressed old school dropouts, you know,
never go on to become Salvador, Dali his secrets. And in fact,
the unspoken rule across all artistic pursuits is that you can get away with
being a weird pretentious dog, as long as your work is very,
very good in all accounts beyond Ali's work is that good has
absolute mastery of representational realism can be seen in basket of bread,
1926,
where he managed to lend an air of stock drama to a painting of a few slices
of buttered bread. Not painting is over 90 years old,
and it's still fresher than anything service they've gone.
And one almost gets the sense that he is mocking his teachers and peers showing
off by putting so much effort and to such a simple scene.
It sounds ridiculous to say there's an oil painting of bread fields.
Sarcastic if you look at it too long, but just try it,
look at it too long. And tell me if it doesn't eventually feel insulting,
just how accurately the bread is painted.
A common critique of modern art is that it's deliberately weird and
incomprehensible in order to cover a lack of foundational skills.
And to be sure there and often is for every actually talented
eccentric there's 20 Pierre Romans zone is pooping into a can and
daring you to buy it. Dolly was not this. He was a popular,
charismatic young fellow who knew the breadth of his skills and pushed himself
beyond what his conscious mind. Good enough.
He studied Freud heavily seeking to unleash the full weight of his creative
forces from the shackles of formal logic. At that time,
the surrealist movement was lost in a directionless Mar preoccupied with
automatic processes of creation. And to this mix,
Dolly added his paranoiac critical method by focusing on abstract threats to the
person in order to induce a paranoid state,
Darlie was able to draw up fantastical images from the deepest recesses of his
mind,
delivering hands painted dream photographs by filtering the real world through
that lens of absolute paranoia in much the same way that humans see faces in
toast or woodgrain Dolly could envision armies of ants, giant eggs,
elephants with impossibly stretched limbs and bulbous protrusions of flesh
held up by crutches.
This period is marked by the frequently recycled image of a child and his
parents on the coastline.
One inspired by a childhood photo of Dolly himself where human figures on to
picked it. They are small and face away from the viewer geometric shapes,
stack Paul to top each other in defiance of balance and gravity early works like
the first days of spring and apparatus and hand show the clear influence of his
contemporary and friend Eve tangy.
Who's also heavily features indecipherable objects and vague Rocky coasts
Eve was also known for eating live spiders.
A party's burning a reputation as an artist has never been easy.
According to the niece of Eve Tanguy Dolly once said to her,
I pinched everything from your uncle Eve of course,
being part of an artistic movement means influencing and being influenced by
others in turn, if it wasn't a failure of early studies of cubism,
Dolly wouldn't have been inspired to experiment with form.
Is he a plagiarist for borrowing the techniques of his friend?
Picasso would Dolly have been Dolly?
Had he not drawn from the influences that he did during the screening of a film?
Donnie wrote age of gold,
the right-wing radical group league of Patriots disrupted the screening a time
to the audience and smashed artworks by even other collaborators decrying the
film and surrealism in general is a poison designed to corrupt the people.
The surrealists responded to this criticism as all great artists do by
getting much weird up dollies fascination with Freud took the forefronts.
As his reputation grew,
he found himself liberated to commit his elicit desires to canvas drawing,
nude forms, tortured beyond recognition. Sex became a curious kind of obsession.
Something you could have gained very easily,
which was denied through a complex web of invisible hangups.
Maybe he hoped that if he delved deep enough into his own subconscious,
you could find the source of these hangups and allow himself to pursue these
desires rather than exercise them upon the canvas. Thankfully for us,
he didn't.
Now you might not have to worry about all of your hard work getting smashed up
by right-wing radicals,
but you do have to worry about backing up your files and the best way to back up
those files is with Backblaze. Now, as you guys know,
I like to try the sponsors that we have on this show.
And indeed I'm using today's sponsor right now, both as I record this video.
And as you probably watch it, my files right now,
I being synced with bank blazer servers. I'm looking over there.
That's where my computer is. You just,
just churning away over there in the background's uploading the videos that I
made this morning to their service. So I have emergency copies of them.
Think about backing stuff up anymore.
I just rest assured the Backblaze is running. It's taken care of it all.
Sometimes I go into the app just to see how it's going.
I was greeted by that warm. You are backed up message. It's pretty beautiful.
I've not yet had to call on them because of a hard disk failure or such a thing
like that. But I know that if that does happen,
I'm all good because I'll just send them a message being like, guys,
I lost a hard desk and well, I can either download all the files,
but that might take a while. It's a lot of files or I can just say, Hey guys,
would you ship me out a disc with all my files on it? And they'll be like, sure,
we'll do that. And it will be encrypted by the way. Of course,
when you upload everything is encrypted as well, super safe.
It's a totally hands off experience, fully recommended.
And you guys get a 15 day free trial right now.
Backblaze is unlimited.
There are no additional charges or fees and it's amazing peace of mind. In fact,
it's the easiest way I know of to get that peace of mind,
which is why I use it so that don't put it off,
see how easy it is with a 15 day free trial,
just go to backblaze.com forward slash biographics and going through that link,
lets them know that we sent you and it helps support the show.
So thank you very much. And let's get back
Indulge me for a moment in a bit of postmodern analysis for,
it seems irresponsible to talk about an artist without talking about his art.
As you're probably aware, it depicts a number of soft melting watches,
draped over a variety of shapes,
such as a tree sleeping figure as an odd rectangular protrusion.
The background is just a distant coastline complete with shadowy catechist
cliffs.
It's easy to read the soft watches as a commentary on the malleable nature of
time. Given Darlie's public appreciation of Einstein's theories,
lacking rigidity and internal structure devoured by a thousand tiny ants.
The ultimate symbol of structure and order finds itself besieged by the
forces of decay. Of course,
Dolly denied all that saying instead the image was a surrealist interpretation
of a runny Canavan cheese that he saw at a picnic. The man loved food,
even actually write a cookbook, which has recently been reissued.
In addition to being both large and expensive,
many of the recipes are deliberately difficult to prepare and assemble either
way. The melting clock is a motif that he would revisit decades later during his
nuclear mysticism phase in the disintegration of the persistence of memory where
the previous city solid shapes have been replaced with a matrix of smaller cubes
referencing the empty space between atoms,
even the ocean in the background finds itself,
appealed upwards like a pancake mid flip.
The realization that everything solid is made up of empty space clearly held a
place of prominence. In Darlie's mind.
The tree is in disintegration marks by prominent gaps in their own continuity.
Everything go here and has been replaced by a grids of tiny versions of
themselves. Perfect approximation of atomic.
Representationalism what subconscious desire was to Don his old work atoms were
to the nuclear mysticism phase one prominent example, gala dare.
If the spheres features a deep field of all this,
which resemble when taken as a whole, a bust of his muse gala,
this veers themselves seem to well and dance around the canvas recalling how
hair moves in winds or electrons spin around a nucleus. If you asked him,
Dolly would have denied the existence of any messages in his work,
in the Dick cavette interview, where he unleashed an anteater on the host,
he answered this,
the melting clock had no meaning that has paintings were just hypnogogic images
drawn from the subconscious five minutes before waking that conflicts with the
theories of Freud,
which would posit a great deal of meaning and the sometimes graphically sexual
imagery that Dali used in his work like the condom shot loaf and cattle and
bread complete with lovingly draped melting clock.
Obviously it's a phallic representation,
but the point of surrealism is that what's an object represents is not fixed or
rotting. Donkey can mean sexual excitement.
If you happen to be a swarm of flies.
When Dali once famously asked at a restaurant, when I order the lobster,
why do you not bring me a telephone? He wasn't just being precious.
He was asking us to evaluate our assumptions about the meaning of images.
What authority gets to define the significance of a melting clock or a Randi
loaf of bread.
The point of surrealism is to bring forth a solid dream into the waking world.
And it's what authority assigns meanings to dreams.
Dolly explained to him that the crunch symbolizes impotence,
that it supports softness, which cannot stand on its own.
But to someone with one leg,
a crutch might represent the difference between helplessness and agency is that
interpretation less valid because it disagrees with the artist
It's in 1929, that Donnelly's upward trajectory.
It becomes undeniable namely through meeting his future wife manager and
co-conspirator gala Don Canova already married to Paul ILADS poets
and co-founder of the surrealist movement,
which gave Donny his signature flat gala was everything.
Donnie was not confidence in her body and sexually accomplished a passionate
affair sooner raised between the two wins gala's marriage to pull and did
shortly thereafter.
The nature of their physical relationship remains an issue of discussion for
perverts.
Dolly was known to say that gala was the only woman he made proper love to
throughout his entire life.
Maybe a lifelong predilection with Catholicism prevented and exploration of his
natural instincts. Either way,
neither of them were contends where even in the sex life,
they were both unfaithful to each other and an oddly inclusive sort of way.
He would watch out with other lovers pleasuring himself. Other times,
Donnie would indulge dalliances with his models and hangers-on by pleasuring
himself, the cycle of admires, they cultivated prized,
ambiguity and androgyny seeking a beauty Unchained by social
expectations of physiology. When it came to choosing Dawn's partners,
gala had her pickup.
[Inaudible].
During the autistic process, Dolly would frequently over his subject habits,
which would later prove problematic.
Garlic maintains the occasional tryst though.
Both were discreet in their indiscretions.
Donny joined at least one of his proteges in a spiritual marriage on the
mountains. Alban's Garland managed an affair in the mid seventies,
do the singer who played Jesus in Jesus Christ, superstar,
Dolly bombastic in his Catholicism could only have been thrilled.
Dolly treated controversy is just another color on his palette.
During one of his first public speeches, as part of the surrealist group,
he insulted the audience and Catalonia as a whole, during a later presentation,
he arrived wearing a full diving suit and almost suffocated.
It was only freed when a companion found a wrench outside and detached the
helmets in his defense,
Dani claims that he wanted to show you that he was fully submerged in the
subconscious control. C was no stranger to his home life. Either.
His parents were skeptical of his relationship with gala who was 10 years older
and abandoned a husband and child to be with him while his connection to his
father had never been particularly stable.
Danny found himself excised from the family after producing a painting,
which was an outline of Jesus into which were written. The words.
Sometimes I spit for fun on my mother's portrait.
His father never forgave him after that,
despite living within sight of each other,
none of Donnelly's family ever visited the house he shared with gala.
The loss of his sister was an especially deep.
If it's not yet clear,
Dani is not a reliable authority on the subject of Dali being such keen expert
of self promotion.
He used every interview as an opportunity to sell a vision of himself as the
artist genius, for example, he probably never smashed on his mother's portrait.
For any reason. He denied supporting Hitler,
even as he included his face in major works. He never clearly denounced fascism.
And instead described himself as a monarchist anarchist in his system.
The King should rule absolutely under which the people could enjoy the freedom
of absolute anarchy. Is that contradictory? Well, yes, of course.
This is Salvador Dali, the Madmen money blue day,
lobster to a telephone and sold it for a million dollars.
It's also exactly the sort of philosophy that would appeal to the divorced ultra
rich used to experiencing life as an extended orgy.
So expect a revival of monarchist anarchism on goop penny day.
Now when the other surreal is dragged him before a kangaroo court and accused
him of fascists sympathies,
he faint illness and showed up wearing too many sweaters.
He would pause his self-defense to take his own temperature, shed layers, Don,
or doff socks,
and do whatever it took to highlight the farcical nature of the proceedings.
His politics remain a major points of contention for both fans and attract us
fascism would have interrupted his ability to enjoy himself.
So it's easy to read his comments, insincerely.
Maybe they were Prato trawling saying the opposite of what his lefty friends
were saying. Just to get attention. However later in life,
Dolly would voice support for general Francisco Franco,
the brutal Spanish dictator calling him the only intelligent man in politics.
When he said this Franco was busy killing 200,000 of his own citizens while
imprisoning 500,000 more. That's not even defensible Assata.
Pablo Picasso turned his back on Dolly and refused to speak to him again.
The surrealists issue to pamphlets announcing Dolly,
and he became persona non grata in the movements and Epic troll. Indeed.
Curious.
Silly enough. His most controversial act is one your least likely to hear about.
As we mentioned, deli had unconventional sexual practices being rich and famous.
He had no shortage of willing partners with one tragically notable exception in
1945,
Dolly was introduced to the Constance Webb by a mutual acquaintance and he was
instantly charmed.
She agreed to Moto for it and providing inspiration for some figures in the film
spell downs.
She described him as a perfect gentleman during the sessions together slowly
coaxing her into working with less and less clothing after their final session.
However, she was relaxing with her arm over our eyes,
and he jumped upon our stomach and upon our breasts,
which she began licking up. She quit muddling for him immediately.
Afterwards only divulging the facts of her assault in interviews after the
artist's death.
This wasn't even his first time crossing that kind of physical line as a young
man, women complimented his beautiful feet.
So he responded by trampling her and only stops when his friends pulled him off
of that. If there was a me too movement in the 1940s,
maybe Dolly would be remembered a little bit differently.
Instead he's much more likely to be rebuked for selling out as if the greatest
moral failing of his life were the advertising campaigns for things like a leg
wear and lollipops. He was the one who designs the current chopper chops logo,
and even insisted on displaying the logo at the top of the pop to ensure that
it's correctly represented.
The question of separating the arts from the artist is ultimately one of
measuring exactly how much misery we're willing to tolerate from creators.
As in exchange for entertainment,
the justification being that this sort of abuse is the price of genius rather
than the side effect of privilege.
Or maybe we all just want to believe that we can get good enough at something,
but the laws of society no longer apply either way.
There's no better place to be an inscrutable genius than the United States.
So well off, he went after moving to America to escape.
The second world war Dolly found great success in New York,
but this proved insufficient to satisfy his hunger for fame.
He had his eyes set on Hollywood.
Having already made a name for himself in cinema circles with the famous
isolating scene from his first movie,
she and under low and delusion dog.
It was easy for Dolly to meet people who could open doors for him.
He was welcomed to California with open arms. Oh,
he's in wallets after painting a few portraits for rich well-connected
socialites,
he was introduced to Alfred Hitchcock and listed Donnie's help for the elaborate
dream sequences in the new auth Thrilla spell spellbound,
sadly only two minutes out of 20 maidens.
The final count of the film and the rest of the footage has been lost a time.
Hitchcock sought out Dolly, not for the press, but because according to him,
no one could better represent the vividness of dreams prior to Dali cinematic,
dream sequences, Misty Vega,
Fez themes and motives were hinted out from behind the layer of plausible
deniability sequence.
Designing for Hollywood is quite the step up from instigating art rights in
Paris. Even if the final project failed to deliver the artists full of vision in
1976,
Dollywood write and direct impressions of upper Golia a documentary about the
search for an enormous psychedelic mushroom.
The climax of the film involves an elaborate flyover of an impossibly colored
alien landscape,
which upon a slow zoom out is revealed to be a Tanisha bras bands on
a pen.
Dolly had spent a week peeing on it is likely through no small coincidence.
The ideal film.
Swallow mushrooms.
His life was marked by tragic fleecing of the millions he earned in his life,
precious little remains of his estate near the end.
He was investigated by the American IRS for tax absurdities.
His hands started to shake so much.
He was often unable to perform the exacting strokes.
He based his work upon after Garland's death,
her body was smuggled back to pupil or wrapped in a blanket in the back of a car
and interned in the console.
She spent so much of our life and as his own health started to fail some
opportunists in Dolly's social circles, seize the opportunity to pilfer,
whatever they could. Money went missing a boarder in his childhood home,
walked off with briefcases full of personal papers and sketches claiming they
were to be documented and photographed in Paris.
Of course they were never seen again,
delirious Dolly would sign whatever canvases and lithograph sheets were pressed
in his hands. And the market was flooded with forged art to this day.
Rumors of newly discovered Dolly masterpieces are usually just convincing fakes
drawn up on a pre-signed sheet up to 50,000.
Such works may have been created and the bulk still remain at large instead of
consigning the works to Spain through his foundation in the Dali museum,
as he declared earlier, dollies signed papers,
seeding copyright to a corporation owns by a time business partner,
even in death Dolly's life was marked by irony.
His initial plan was to construct a team adjacent the gala's resting place with
the hole between them such that they could hold hands in the afterlife.
Instead the mayor of figure intervenes just hours before Delaney's death and
claims that the artist had charged him with moving the final resting place to
the Dani theater and museum conveniently giving us a huge tourist attraction.
And that was the end of Dali. And I really hope you enjoyed today's video.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Also please do support this channel by supporting our fantastic sponsor.
Backblaze linked to them below and thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].